okay so everyone always thinks about
Pinocchio's nose because it's quite
literally right there in your face but
have you ever considered this in order
to keep standing Pinocchio would need to
bend backwards significantly to balance
out the added weight of that branch and
eventually even the bird's nest at the
end but look
Pinocchio isn't leaning back at all to
compensate which means that he must have
some kind of counterbalance growing in
his uh-oh
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show that has
no corporate strings to hold us down
which is why we get to talk about things
like child slavery and Disney films
that's right today we're going all the
way back to that Disney classic about
the exploitation of child laborers in
ochio now as a kid this movie just
really provided me with years worth of
Nightmare fuel
I mean monstros mouth anyone children
turning into literal work mules it's
terrifying but looking back on it now
Pinocchio actually raises a lot of
questions like did people really just
throw money during marionette shows like
some kind of puppet strip club if people
who go to Pleasure Island become
jackasses are the other animals that we
see throughout the movie also people
core are they're just animals who
actually do walk around as living
creatures what about this Fox is awfully
human what about Jiminy Cricket we
haven't even gotten into the logistics
of literally lighting a fire inside a
whale sadly though all these questions
are gonna have to wait for another day
because today we are tackling everyone's
favorite subject business specifically
the business of Pleasure Island the
bizarro 1940s bad boys utopia today's
episode is all about the incredibly
scary reality that Pleasure Island as we
see it in the movie Pinocchio could have
actually existed in real life I like to
call this episode How to Succeed in
child slavery Without Really Trying but
first a recap because I can't assume
that you guys have seen this Pinocchio
is really old at this point I mean the
kids nowadays tangled is probably like
the furthest back they go and call it a
Disney classic oh boy anyway this guy
name Geppetto is a clock maker and a
vaguely European disney-esque country
around the turn of the century who makes
a marionette named Pinocchio and then
wishes for him to become a real boy boy
the Blue Fairy comes down and grants his
wish but in a pure dick move only grants
the wish half way because apparently
fairies can just do that for the lols
I've given you life because
night Geppetto wished for a real boy by
a real boy
no Pinocchio so instead of Pinocchio
becoming a real boy he instead becomes a
living puppet monster Geppetto wakes up
sees that his marionette has come to
life and like anyone would do in this
situation
goes back to sleep the next morning
though he then shoves Pinocchio out the
door saying hey you've existed for 12
hours now surely you can figure out
school right on the way Pinocchio meets
two Foxy swindlers Honest John foul
fellow and Gideon who proceeded to
swindle Pinocchio several times and
doing multiple stupid things like
becoming an actor until finally leaving
with them to Pleasure Island along with
a horde of kidnapped children once
Pinocchio and the small army of young
boys arrived at Pleasure Island did they
drink Smok trash a mansion and destroy
all the rides so basically they become
the 1940s equivalent of team 10 every
day bro but every good vacation has to
come to an end and the boys start to
regret all that indulgence when they
start turning into literal dog games
it's revealed that the big scheme behind
the entirety of Pleasure Island is to
transform boys into donkeys who are then
sold off to work in salt mines while the
owners of Pleasure Island to make
themselves a hefty little profit or is
there actually a profit to be had here
at all this whole thing sounds so
ridiculous and far-fetched is there any
chance that kidnapping kids transforming
them into donkeys and then selling them
off to the highest bidder is actually a
profitable business venture I mean look
at this the kids destroy the amusement
park so should the owners of Pleasure
Island just scrap their half-assed plans
or I guess in this case fully asked
plans I just sell off the park to become
yet another Six Flags
no no they shouldn't child kidnapping
and donkey sales are actually
surprisingly profitable and I'm about to
show you how aren't Disney episodes fun
so the first question is how much is a
donkey actually worth going by a coin
now Dom's prices it seems like most
jackasses today sell between $500 and
$2,000 each unless of course you're an
MTV branded jackass in which case you're
worth two and a half million dollars
since our child jackasses are certainly
more intelligent than most will use the
$2,000 per jackass price range you are a
great talker you were like top dog
since Pinocchio happens sometimes
around the late 1800s or early 1900s as
indicated by the ferris wheel first
introduced in 1893 we're gonna adjust
for inflation and estimate that each
donkey is selling for about seventy six
dollars in Pinocchio's time and just how
many of these donkeys is the coachman
able to sell off in a batch well to
answer that we first need to know how
many little boys he's gotten himself a
bulldog
the best way to estimate the total
donkey load isn't actually to count the
boys at pleasure island but rather it's
to look at how they all got there this
Mississippi style steamboat that
transports all the boys to the island
also tells us how many victims we're
gonna be looking at passenger river
boats of this size with three decks have
an absolute max capacity of 2150 five
people so given the Coachman's
unscrupulous morals and lack safety
records I mean just look at the kids
falling between Ferris wheel cars we can
assume that he's stuffing the maximum
number of kids onto this thing as
possible especially since children are
so much smaller than adults and these
boys aren't carrying any luggage so
we're gonna subtract a standard 50
people to account for the boat crew of a
steamer that large which leaves us with
room for a whopping 2105 young boys it's
truly a pretty horrifying level of evil
that's going on here in Pleasure Island
that's not even accounting for all the
rampant racism and underage smoking so
multiplying everything out we have 2100
for donkeys wheat minus 1 because
Pinocchio escapes $76 each gives us one
hundred and fifty nine thousand nine
hundred and four dollars which might not
seem like all that much but remember
this is money way back at the turn of
the century accounting for inflation the
coachmen is looking to net a whopping
four million two hundred eight thousand
dollars that's four million of twenty
eighteen dollars so things are looking
pretty good for the old coachman here
rights but the one thing that every
businessman will tell you is that before
you go walking off with your profits you
need to start calculating your overhead
and running pleasure island isn't a
simple operation so we need to factor in
the costs of two thousand boys drinking
themselves under the table while
destroying an entire amusement park as I
pointed out earlier in just one night a
boatload of boys managed to level
Pleasure Island into a desolate
hellscape it's like the world of Fallout
what's worse than a nuclear apocalypse
aw just two thousand young rambunctious
boys lookin to scrap smoke and drink so
how much is it costing the coachman to
rebuild an entire amusement park every
time they bring one of these boatloads
over well initially I calculated out
every little piece of wood and every
glass pane broken in here but what I
found out was that most of the repairs
were actually just small items that
ultimately didn't make that big of a
difference on the bottom line at most we
were looking at about a thousand dollars
on tobacco which translates to about
thirty-eight old-timey dollars and about
two hundred inflation-adjusted dollars
to restock the destroyed mansion with
more old furniture for the boys to tear
apart both of those numbers not nearly
enough to hit the Coachman's bottom line
the bigger ticket items though is where
they get you namely the rides if we're
running this business we're basically
gonna need to replace the ferris wheel
cars in the entirety of the carousel
which looks like the central axis has
actually been bent down the middle this
all begs a completely separate question
what kind of Hell beasts are these
children I mean what would enable them
to even be able to try bending a
carousel in half and how many children
did it take to accomplish that sort of
thing or was it just one super kid maybe
some solid steel marionette who's also
on his way to becoming a real boy too
anyway these are the expensive things to
replace but when you actually run the
numbers they don't wind up being all
that expensive Ferris wheels are
surprisingly cheap which is honestly
kind of scary to think about as you
dangle 40 feet in the air on one smaller
used Ferris wheels cost as little as
fifteen thousand dollars back in 2008
the Santa Monica Ferris wheel was put on
sale on eBay for a mere $50,000 and it's
worth noting that that Ferris wheel is
both large and famous which is jacking
up the cost so we're gonna assume that
the coachman isn't feeling too spendy
here and we'll go with that $15,000
estimate or 572 old timey adjusted
dollars still nothing that's even close
to making a dent into his total profits
now the carousel is gonna run you a bit
higher the cheapest option is from the
carousel works for about three hundred
and twenty thousand dollars or twelve
thousand dollars in inflation-adjusted
costs now they wouldn't have to buy a
whole new carousel every time so long as
the turntable still worked but from what
I can tell in carousel terms that thing
is totaled which means that the coachman
is gonna be forking out twelve thousand
dollars for a new merry-go-round every
time he does
one of these little trips so between the
two major rides that need to be replaced
with every new batch of kids plus all
the smaller incidentals I mentioned the
coachman is looking at about thirteen
thousand dollars worth of operating
costs which still leaves him with a
hundred forty six thousand nine hundred
four dollars or four million dollars of
twenty eighteen money but the biggest
cost here is actually still coming
kidnapping the boys in the first place
the coachman has to pay lowlife scum
like Honest John with a big ol sack
elude that we actually get to see this
sack aleut is so big that it would be
totally devastating to carry and ran
calculations on the amount of gold this
thing holds by comparing it to the size
and capacity of a standard german beer
stein which we see it lined up against
in this shot it comes out to about
nineteen hundred cubic inches of gold
which converts to a whopping 1211 troy
ounces or 83 pounds of gold don't you be
forgetting about leg day coachman now
this has got to be the amount of gold
traded to fill the entire boat and this
by far is the Coachman's largest expense
per night coming in at 1 million six
hundred thirty one thousand seven
hundred eighty-five dollars and ninety
three cents as of writing this script
that converts to sixty three thousand
one hundred seventy nine dollars in
Pinocchios terms
oh poor coachman look at all those human
trafficking profits just melting away
now our total earnings per boatload of
boys has been sliced in half
coming to about eighty three thousand
seven hundred and twenty five dollars
every time or a bit over two million now
honestly that wouldn't be too bad of a
profit for kidnapping two thousand
children and selling them off as donkeys
but we're still neglecting one huge
consideration here this whole time we've
just been assuming that Pleasure Island
was just there but the park had to be
built in the first place and building
the park is gonna be a huge investment
for any child kidnappers to be so let's
look at the big-ticket items here first
there's the cost of that swell
rollercoaster even small steel cookie
cutter roller coasters cost about five
million dollars up front to build or
about $190,000 in Pinocchios time that
cost alone is more than one night could
possibly earn at Pleasure Island so we
know that this isn't the Coachman's
first time at the rodeo
he is truly talking from experience when
he says
why in order to make this business
anywhere close to profitable he's gonna
need more than one boatload of boys now
add to that the cost of actually
building the structures that we see on
the park grounds including walls giant
gate mansion a tower a pool hall slides
and suddenly the costs start growing
really fast
luckily Pleasure Island is much smaller
than most amusement parks having only a
few rides and only intending to host
about 2,000 guests at a time so we'll
have to do some scaled estimates based
on costs of other similarly sized parks
luckily we can use the recent expansion
of universals Diagon Alley for Harry
Potter land a project that cost a
reported four hundred million dollars to
make
now that four hundred million does
include a hundred million for the escape
from Gringotts ride so we'll have to
knock that one off but that still leaves
us with three hundred million dollars
for one small section of a theme park
even in Pinocchio's time that is a
whopping eleven point four million
dollars if Pleasure Island were even
only the size of just that one small
section of a park there would still be a
huge amount of upfront costs in creating
this business one that would take the
coachmen years to recoup so this whole
thing seems busted then writes with an
upfront cost of 11.5 million dollars
between the roller-coaster the park the
other rides the employees 76210 dollars
in costs every time the coachman brings
in another batch and they completely
trashed the place he would need to bring
in a hundred and thirty nine boatloads
of small boys to Pleasure Island before
he would even start to turn a profit
that translates to a whopping 292
thousand children it's gonna be
impossible rights no no it's not the
Coachman's main source of children
during this time would have been orphans
france kept remarkable records of child
abandonment in the 19th century but they
were basically the only country who did
so we'll have to work off of their
numbers France recorded about a hundred
and sixty four thousand abandoned
children annually in the mid-1800s and
that's just one of many European nations
the coachman and his goons could have
been traveling if Italy and Spain had
even half of those numbers the coachman
could have shockingly made his money
back in less
and a year from only the abandoned
children of three European countries
going into year two it's actually
conceivable that he could have been
running the most profitable enterprise
in all of Europe while most other
countries would have had no idea because
they weren't even keeping records of
orphans and why how was he able to do
this why are there so many parentless
children walking around because of all
the wars happening in europe during this
era most of these orphans were children
whose parents had died in the war those
are the children that we see the
coachmen snatching up and reselling in
an unbelievable twist the supply of
abandoned children during this time
period in this part of the world was so
incredibly high that the coachman could
have actually pulled off kidnapping and
reselling 292,000 children making it one
of the most heinous and cold-blooded
acts in history this is the truly
horrifying levels of evil that we see at
play in Pinocchio and worst of all the
coachman totally gets away with it in
the movie old-school Disney is pretty
hardcore
but Pinocchio is especially brutal
because in this case we never see any
kind of justice served to any of the
villains in this film in our quote
unquote good ending the only one we see
getting rescued is Pinocchio he's the
only one all of the other 2,000 children
that we see enter Pleasure Island that
we actually watch get transformed into
donkeys all of them don't escape all of
them don't have a Blue Fairy protecting
them all of them get sold off into the
salt mines to the highest bidder and the
coachman and Honest John and Gideon are
all left to run their business for
another day just think about that next
time you hear Jiminy Cricket talking
about wishing upon a star I know about
three hundred thousand kids who'd like
another crack at their wish but hey
that's just a theory
a film theory and apropos to nothing I
think everyone deserves a chance to
watch the first five seconds of
Pinocchio in outer space the adventure
Europe
is based on a true portrayal of outer
space
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]